la ciudad eterna sigue su ritmo de vida
tras el revuelo electoral una Romana de
nacimiento la ultraderechista Georgia
meloni ganó el domingo las elecciones al
frente de una coalición junto al también
ultraderechista Mateo salvini y Alex
Primer Ministro Silvio berlusconi una
preocupación para extensionistas
minorías y detractores en general
para la comunidad lgbt pero también para
el 60% de los italianos creo que votaron
en contra esta mayoría parlamentaria
significa perder derechos
en su discurso posterior a la cita
electoral melonia aseguró que gobernará
para todos los italianos
lo haremos con la intención de unir a la
gente de potenciar lo que les une y no
lo que les divide
es este Matiz discursivo junto a
discursos del pasado cercano en contra
de la identidad de género y lo que
denominan el lobby lgtbi lo que preocupa
a la comunidad Sí a la familia natural
no a los lobbys el gbt si a la identidad
sexual durante las últimas semanas
preelectorales melón y modelo su
discurso y tampoco hace referencia
explícita a ello en su programa
electoral esto sin embargo no rebaja el
nerviosismo
Tenemos una gran preocupación por las
nuevas generaciones porque están creando
una batalla ideológica debido también a
la profunda crisis económica
precisamente uno de los últimos en
felicitar a melón y ha sido el
presidente de Hungría Víctor Urban quien
aprobó leyes en contra del colectivo
lgtbi entre tanto Italia espera noticias
sobre la formación del próximo gobierno
Este martes desde fratelli de Italia
aseguraron que se buscará Un gobierno de
los mejores sin pensar en las banderas
de los partidos en el país transalpino y
ya se interpreta como un freno a las
aspiraciones de Mateo salvini para ser
de nuevo ministro del interior